The Lino Spiteri Foundation
works very closely
through the national employment agency,
Jobsplus,
to support local enterprises
in the recruitment
of people with a disability
They helped me search for work
and attend appointments.
Last year we were looking for staff
to help us in the cleaning of our restaurant
and we came across services offered
by the Lino Spiteri Foundation.
The job needs to be tailor-made
to fit into the individual's abilities.
They helped me a lot in this process
from interviewing
to find the right candidate,
for the skills for the job.
So once the individual
is chosen for employment
the job coach can guide
the person to employment
until the person is independent.
They come during the week
to see how they are doing
if we need to help them
in something else, in training.
Everyone helped me to learn the job
and explained the work done here.
I learnt well and I can help people.
We are happy to contribute because
we believe that people with special needs
have also skills and can help the company.
I have a good boss, I have other colleagues
and I made a lot of friends.
They are really friendly
and as I respect them,
they respect me as well.